all good things who come to an end  pretty little liars is ending after  season 7 the next 10 episodes of the  show really are going to be the last 10  episodes of the series the news was  announced Monday during a facebook live  just ahead of the show summer finale  airing tuesday ET was with the cast in  june and there were rumblings a series  would end but not completely do you  think this is the last season do you  know anything I mean we have been told  this is the end of PLL as we know it I  think it's not going to die completely I  don't know which direction it's going to  go in it's probably the last season with  a full cast which is what's made it you  know what it is it may continue in some  way shape or form with new people or  keep some of the cast long live PLL this  is definitely the most romantic season  and it's also the most deadly there's a  lot of drama but it's also I think the  fans are going to enjoy it so if it is  our last season it's still going to be  magical